Sony Online Entertainment sparks its
jumper cables and reanimates its own
early access survival game it's called
h1z1 and yes it's basically dayz you
start with nothing but the clothes you
wear and a flashlight you mindlessly
search for loot you constantly look for
directions and apparently you wear
motorcycle helmets but it doesn't take
long to realize the differences many of
which are for the better keep in mind
these are observations as of January
2015 JZ wins best-looking but if this
were a beauty pageant
h1z1 was actually able to answer the
questions the game undeniably runs
smoother than daisies poor optimization
compared to Daisy the dead in h1z1 Kari
loot and respond better to things like
headshots and the noises you make Daisy
looks real hot on the fashion runway mm
get a girl with such an extensive
wardrobe that makes h1z1 look like a bum
but how about some brain power in both
games you make bows and fireplaces to
cook food yet an h1z1 you make MacGyver
proud makeshift hatchets animal traps
hand shovel spears do collectors flares
compasses the list goes on but for the
real kicker you can craft shelters
so you pump in some hours your fit is
pimp your arsenal stacked alright well
now what Daisy just kind of falls into a
deathmatch only thing to do I guess is
kill other people hey what's up go in
h1z1 you chop down trees and build a
home you're searching for that perfect
little patch of green you've always
dreamed up far far away from all those
stupid who want to search your cold dead
body
what's a 50 player server like in dayz
well chances are you will die alone and
that's part of the game right other than
knowing the map is roughly one-fourth
the size of dayz it's not clear what the
server size is like in h1z1 but what is
clear is that you will run into many
players and most of them are lying
backstabbing apples here's a comparison
of the two where I played for roughly
about two hours in each game
sorry I answered ooh he wasn't he was
not even he wasn't gonna comply just go
that way take a right there take a left
all right so hey how was that for what I
gathered from this is that dying so
often in h1z1 made you less cautious and
defensive in turn you tend to take more
risks with strangers
granted SOE has stated they plan on
increasing the map size to the point
where they intend for player interaction
to be minimal but I personally loved it
some people don't though and that's all
good well there's no denying h1z1 has
set down some pretty damn solid
framework so for now it's just another
waiting game I gotta go but if you want
to shoot me in the face and kill me
that'd be amazing
I'm going crazy sweet my browser history
see you nice